Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I wanna talk about something
important, uh, maybe more important than
language learning, and it's learning,
learning throughout our lives, learning as
adults, learning as people who are growing
older, learning as a major driver of
health, of, uh, happiness, uh, of success.
And the reason I'm talking about that is
I just finished listening to an audiobook
in German by my favorite, uh, German
neuroscientist, Manfred Spitzer, uh, where
he speaks with another gentleman whose
name was Norbert Hershkowitz, and they
talk about ... how adults think and learn.
And there are three books and the
last one in particular ... living
throughout your life, uh, 60 years
plus ... like how old people think.
And there's a lot of very
interesting information there.
I'll leave a link to the book, uh, if
you want to find it, if you understand
German, but it got me to thinking
about this whole issue of learning.
In fact, I, I focused my discussions
here on, on language learning and then
my interest in language earning and
tips that I have based on my experience.
But you know, I realized that
that learning I is a huge
issue in our lives today.
Governments spend a fortune
on education and health.
Those two items typically account for 20%
of, uh, GDP in most developed countries.
Uh, learning though is something
that depends on the individual,
not on how much money the
government or other people spend.
I should add in, in terms of this
whole learning thing um, when I see
the, the amount of student debt that
people accumulate, especially in the
United States, it kind of puts them
at a great disadvantage, although
statistically they'll end up earning more
and, uh, probably have other benefits.
So learning is a major issue
and never before has it been
so easy to learn things.
I mean, people have always learned.
They've learned by
watching people do things.
They've learned by trial and
error, doing things themselves.
But reading and listening, like the audio
book that I just mentioned is a very
quick and easy way of acquiring knowledge.
And whenever we're acquiring
knowledge, our brains are changing
and growing and remaining young.
And, uh, so it is important to
take advantage of these things.
The ability to take advantage of
these things relies on our curiosity.
Uh, again, Manfred Spitzer, uh, in
his, uh, audiobook, he references
Einstein who said, I have no more
talent than anyone else, is just
that I am passionately curious.
So curiosity is the driver.
Curiosity is why I have
so many books behind me.
This is only one of seven big
bookshelves that I have in my house.
I'm interested in things and it's
important to remain interested in things.
Sometimes when people talk about
learning, they overly complicate things.
So I did some research, uh, using
Google, uh, and I just punched in there
how old people think and learn, uh,
learning and aging and so forth, and a
lot of the sort of advice that's given
is, you know, over complicating, like
older people, they prefer repetition.
Well, repetition has its place in
education, whether you're old or young.
Uh, older people are more
self-directed, says one.
I don't see that necessarily
as being the case.
Um, again, it is not clear
who they mean by older.
Uh, there's reference to the
number of neurons we lose.
Obviously there's a sort of
an evolution in our brains.
But, uh, Spitzer points out, we
have so many neurons that we can
afford to lose quite a lot of them.
We do lose some over time.
It doesn't really affect anything.
Uh, perhaps we have, you know, uh,
weaker memories at a certain point.
But the point is, if you continue
learning, you will strengthen
all of those cognitive functions.
But here again, one of these articles
that I came up with, uh, I might leave
these if you're interested, I can leave
some links to them, sort of applies that
a college education is very important
to your mental health as you grow older.
Implication being that someone
who has had a college education
has learned so many things.
Perhaps they're more curious about
things, they will continue learning.
They've got a base that's gonna help
them, but nothing prevents a person
who doesn't have a college education
from being equally curious and, you
know, reading and listening, and
keeping their brains stimulated.
Spitzer also makes the point that it's
not just a matter of keeping your brain
active, like doing Sudoku, because
Sudoku is not bringing anything new in,
and it's very important, I've seen this
elsewhere, that you bring in things that
are new, you discover new things that
change you in a way, and that by, you
know, processing this new information,
then, uh, you are maintaining the, the
youth and the, the activity of your, of
your brain, uh, which is very important.
Uh, of course, other things...
being active is very good for your brain.
Uh, jogging is good for your brain.
So many things are good for your brain,
but it, it, I don't know that we need
to think of it always in terms of doing
it because it's good for our brains.
If we are genuinely curious, then
we derive tremendous satisfaction
from learning about other places.
Learning...
travel is a form of
learning about other places.
Learning languages, of course, which
is what I'm doing now, learning
Polish because I'm going to Poland.
I mean, I did have some
previous exposure to Polish.
Uh, so it's this curiosity rather than
how many years we've spent at school.
And also, again, in some of these, um,
articles, I found there was a great
reliance on these theories of, uh,
different kinds of learners that older
people might be more visual learners
or might be more kinetic learners.
And, of course that whole theory
of different types of learners has
largely been debunked, and I think
we're guided more by our curiosity.
Uh, some people don't like to read, uh,
which is fine, but the way the brain
learns is essentially the same, uh, with
all people, and that's more or less become
accepted as the fact and these efforts
by educators to categorize people as this
kind of learner or that kind of learner.
Or if you're a young learner, then
it's this way and if you're an
older learner, it's some other way.
Uh, I'm not, uh, impressed with those.
I think, uh, I prefer the simple position
that I may have lost some neurons, but as
long as I'm curious, if I keep discovering
new things, learning new things, reading
books, learning languages, it's gonna
keep my brain as young as it can be,
given the fact that I'm 77 years old.
So, there you have it.
I just wanted to sort of broaden,
because I always talk about language
learning, but actually I'm learning i,
I'm interested in education as a whole.
I read quite a bit on the subject
and I think it's a vital part of
being, you know, fully engaged as
human beings, uh, at whatever age.
So there you have it.
Just a little bit of a digression
from language learning.
I hope you found that interesting.
I look forward to your comments.
Bye for now.